It’s estimated that seatbelts have collectively
saved over one million lives, making them
one of the most cost-effective public health
inventions ever made.
[1] These incredible devices can reduce fatalities
in car accidents by about half.
Yet their development and implementation as
standard equipment was surprisingly rocky.
For something that seems so straightforward,
the humble seatbelt is more sophisticated
than you may think.
Even though wearing a restraint in a vehicle
moving 100 kilometers per hour may seem like
common sense to us today.
It took many years to convince the driving
public to buckle up, a problem that persists
in many countries around the world.
This ingenius device saves lives, and this
is how it does it.
In 1903 race car driver Barney Oldfield became
the first person to drive over 100 km/h.
He was all too aware of the dangers he was
subjecting himself to and commissioned Leslie
Leroy Irvin, another dare devil of the 1920s,
to develop a harness for his racing cars.
Irvin had developed his own static line parachute
to jump out of airplanes, and 1919 became
the first American to jump out of a plane
and manually deploy a parachute from a backpack
in midair.
A design he helped the US military to develop.[2]
The harness they came up with did not catch
on however.
Despite its life saving potential, it had
a number of problems.
First, they were simply uncomfortable, which
discouraged drivers and passengers from wearing
them.
Then there was the very real problem of “seat
belt syndrome,” injuries directly related
to wearing a seatbelt during a collision.
Early seatbelts only went across the lap.
In the event of a crash, this rigid single
point restraint, laying in line with vital
organs and the lumbar spine, could cause severe
injuries.
[3]
The prevailing thought at the time was that
it would be better to be ejected from the
vehicle, which might catch on fire or go under
water, than to remain inside of it during
a crash by being stopped forcefully by a thin
piece of fabric.
Despite rising fatalities and injuries during
the rise of the automobile from the 1920s
to 1950s, the general public showed little
interest in wearing seatbelts. [4]
Even though Nash Motors installed seat belts
in 40,000 cars, only about 1000 of them were
actually used by drivers.
[5] When Ford led a marketing campaign in
1955 to promote seat belts and other safety
options, they too faced public backlash.
However, in the 1950s resistance began to
ebb away with a new innovation by Swedish
engineer Nils Bohlin.
Bohlin first began developing safety features
for Saab, including an ejection seat, but
was then poached by the president of Volvo.
He experimented with several designs, including
a seatbelt that fastened between the legs,
an idea which 95 % of my audience just gasped
at, [6] He ultimately settled on the design
we’re familiar with today.
The three point harness.
This set up more evenly distributes the forces
of a crash across the shoulders and hips.
[7]
Bohlin was able to prove the effectiveness
of this design and received the U.S. patent
for it in 1962.
But rather than profit from it, the design
was released for free, paving the way for
a new and incredibly important safety feature.
[8]
While certain elements of the seat belt have
been modified and improved over time, the
main design remains the same.
We need a way for the strap itself to wind
and unwind under normal circumstances.
Allowing passengers to easily move around,
and take it on and off without adjusting its
size for different passengers and drivers.
We have all experienced that annoying phenomenon
where you try to put on a seatbelt too quickly
causing it to jam.
This happens as a result of a false alarm
in the seatbelt mechanism.
This mechanism.
It has a number of components, the simplest
being this spiral torsion spring.
When the seatbelt is unwound it spins a cylinder
at the center of this torsion spring, pulling
the spring into the center into a compressed
state, storing energy that can retract the
seat belt tightly against your body once the
the belt buckle is locked into the buckle
socket.
This mechanism is usually attached to one
side of the webbing spool, while the locking
mechanism that will prevent the spool from
being unwound at all during a crash is located
on the other side.
For this mechanism to work we need a way to
detect a crash extremely quickly.
One kind of locking mechanism reacts to the
momentum change of the vehicle.
Just as our bodies want to continue moving
forward in a crash, a weighted mechanism inside
the seatbelt will too.
First we need a ratchet gear, like this, attached
to the same cylinder at the center of our
torsion spring.
This gear will be engaged to prevent rotation.
Now we need a mechanism that can engage this
gear when the car decelerates.
This can be done with a weight pendulum.
When the car decelerates this weight will
swing forward, causing its opposite end to
jam into the ratchet, preventing it from rotating
any further.
Like any good safety mechanism there is a
redundancy in its design, being backed up
by another locking mechanism.
One you can test without crashing your car,
by tugging on your seatbelt hard enough this
mechanism will activate.
As it depends on centrifugal force to activate.
Two weighted levers are attached to the central
spool.
When the central spool unwinds at a normal
speed, these levers do not create enough force
to overcome the force of a spring that pushes
them towards the center.
But, if the webbing comes out in a sudden
jerk, the centrifugal force exceeds the force
of the spring and the levers push outwards
engaging the locking teeth and prevent further
rotation.
There is another final safety mechanism added
to make seat belts even safer.
When driving we often slump forward slightly,
leaving slack between our body and the seat.
In the event of a crash it’s best if we
are tightly held against the seat, so there
is a mechanism within seat belts that actually
forcefully pulls us against the seat during
a crash.
This mechanism is fired electronically by
the same sensor that initiates the explosive
that expands airbags, and this mechanism is
also fired by an explosive charge.
Animation 6
It’s called the pretensioner.
A chamber at the bottom of the device has
two electrodes, an igniter material and a
piston.
When the car’s central processor detects
a collision, it applies an electric current
that ignites the explosive and the sudden
burst of pressure forces a mechanism to actuate.
To quickly retract the seat belt and pull
the passenger tightly against the seat.
Finally, the seatbelt has several mechanisms
built in to reduce the risk of seat belt syndrome–injuries.
Some webbing has a fold sewn into it, with
stitches that will break when a set amount
of force is applied, allowing the person to
move forward a bit more.
Animation 7
There is also the torsion bar, a length of
metal attached to the rotating spool.
This torsion bar is designed to twist and
absorb some of the force from a crash, instead
of allowing that energy to be transferred
to the passengers body..
[9]
Despite the clear benefits of this three-point
belt system, it took decades before the use
of seatbelts really became widespread.
Although Wisconsin was the first state to
require all cars to install seat belts in
the front in 1961, it wasn’t until 1984
that another state, New York, required passengers
to actually wear them.
I remember growing in Ireland in the 90s and
seeing the change in opinions about seatbelts,
and I especially remember moving to Malaysia,
a country with a terrible road safety record
and where a friend of mine died because he
wasn’t wearing a seatbelt, and arguing with
local co-workers who refused to wear them.
The National Highway Traffic Safety Administration
estimates 15,000 lives are saved by seat belts
every year in the U.S. alone, so please put
your seatbelts on.
They do save lives.
Of course there are plenty of other technologies
helping to make cars safer.
We have front and side airbags, crumple zones,
driver assist, and automatic emergency braking.
And Volvo is now proposing a blanket-style
seat belt for its autonomous cars that would
keep passengers safe and comfortable even
when they’re napping. [10] But that’s
still something of a pipe-dream, since we’re
still a ways away from self-driving cars.
For now we are stuck with the three-point
harness, a simple and cheap device to keep
passengers safe.
Sometimes simple solutions really are the
most effective.
Other times more complicated solutions are
needed.
One concept is so complicated that I struggle
to wrap my head around it.
I have a basic understanding of how computers
work, and a firm grasp of physics, but the
physics of quantum computing goes right over
my head.
I wanted to start learning more about it in
preparation for a future video, but my usual
method of using college textbooks was not
helping me.
I didn’t know what I didn’t know, which
makes asking the right questions really hard.
Then I discovered that Brilliant has a new
course on quantum computing, created in partnership
with quantum computing researchers.
It took me from the very basics of quantum
computing, starting at a level I understand
with basic logic gates.
Testing my understanding along the way and
explaining to me the correct answers in clear
understandable terms when I got something
wrong.
I regularly have to dive into the deep end
of unfamiliar topics to write the scripts
for this channel, and the most difficult part
is usually knowing what questions to ask,
but Brilliant removes that challenge with
curated guided courses designed to gradually
level up your knowledge.
You can take this course, or one of Brilliant's
many other courses, including our very own
partnered course, by signing up to Brilliant's
free trial with the link in the description,
our by going to Brilliant.org/realengineering.
And if you found it valuable, which I am sure
you will, you can continue with 20% off the
annual premium subscription.
This offer is available to the first 500 people
to sign up.
Brilliant teaches with interesting and fun
interactive courses that challenge you along
the way, making the learning process much
easier and more rewarding.
And they’re adding content monthly, so there’s
always something new to learn.
You can get started for free by clicking the
link on screen now, and the first 500 people
to do so will get 20% off Brilliant's annual
premium subscription.